Fundamentally, the use of dynamics,
is what's different between just doing
detection, and actually doing tracking.
And that's shown as an example here.
Here we have 20 frames taken.
And here's some dude right there.
You can see that he's
walking across all these.
And we just like to keep track of him.
And of course, he's changing
his appearance every frame.
He's not going to look identical
from one frame to the next.
So, detection, we independently
detect the person each time.
Right?
So, we maybe have a little model of what
this person looks like, and
we run it maybe all over the image, and
we say uh-huh, you know, he's here.
Uh-huh, he's here.
Uh-huh, he's there.
And, just these there.
No more uh-huh's,
cause it's like not exciting anymore.
Okay, so that's detection.
Tracking, we do a little different.
What we do is we predict
the new location
of the object based upon
the estimated dynamics.
And I say estimated dynamic, because for
example, this guy, he's walking, so
maybe we est,
maybe he's got a constant velocity, but
we don't know what that
velocity is a priority, right?
We have to estimate it, right?
So here we have an example
where we detect him here.
And it says, you know, we'll
estimate the velocity, but maybe we
estimated zero velocity, or we have some
prior reason to believe he's moving to
the left, because this is a sidewalk
where people move to the left often.
Fine.
That allows us to make
a prediction in the next image
of where that person will be and
then we detect them.
So now we can do two things.
First of all, we can improve our
estimate of where he is based upon both
our detection and our prediction.
And second, now we do have
a reasonable estimate of the velocity.
So we can use that velocity to predict
in the third fame, detect etc., etc.,
and we iterate.
So this is what the,
the basic tracking loop is.